- La mia botta di c**o più grande è aver vinto
un gratta e vinci da 300 mila euro con
annessi 6.000 euro al mese per vent'anni.
La mia sfiga è essermi fidata di mia madre
mi aveva detto che ci volevano tre
simboli per vincere quella somma e
quindi io ho buttato il gratta e vinci. Ne bastavano due. Ciao
- Tu stai piangendo - Avevo paura che finisse "E quindi l'ho ammazzata
- Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di Vita
Buttata, il tema della puntata di oggi è "Botte di c**o". Si può dire botte di c**o? "Colpi di fortuna"
Per un tema così speciale ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una ragazza che diciamo è stata
baciata dalla fortuna prima che questa
si rifacesse le labbra, questa ragazza
sta a una gioia un po' come Pamela Prati
sta a Marco Caltagirone. Sto parlando della
migliore amica di mia cugina, Morgana
- Ciao - Da quant'è che ci conosciamo noi, sedici anni?     - Beh saranno
almeno sedici si, oggi è 16 diciamo 16 - Ah in tutto
questo ragazzi è il compleanno di
Morgana, quindi Enrico... - Auguri (Enrico) - No cantale la
canzone che avevano detto che le avresti
cantato per oggi - In do maggiore
♫ Il signore sta nel suo santo tempio (Enrico) ♫
- Che cos'era?
Che cos'è il signore sta nel suo santo tempio? - Scary Movie (Enrico)
- Bando alle ciance, su apriamo qui, ti prego...
Cin, tanti auguri - Tanti auguri, cin (Enrico)
- Parliamo di botte di c**o
Sono curioso di vedere che cosa - No io ho bevuto...(*incomprensibile*) - Che cosa hai detto?
- No dico io ho bevuto perché di solito quando si brinda si beve, tu non hai bevuto
Non sapevo se portasse male ma - No no porta sfiga        - C'è stato un particolare momento della
mia vita di circa un anno in cui
qualsiasi posto andavo trovavo soldi a
terra. Fatto sta che una volta entro
dentro un centro commerciale, appena alla
destra dell'ingresso c'è un bancomat e
al momento in cui ci passo davanti
escono 250 euro - Questo si chiama però svaligiare pure eh
Cioè questa si chiama rapina. Quanto è stato
il massimo che hai trovato per terra?
5 centesimi, ma davvero perché non ho
mai trovato soldi per terra - Ma perché tu
non sei una che si guarda attorno?
Tu non sei una che guarda per terra
tu sei una che guarda il cielo quando
cammina - E' vero! Mazza che visione romantica che hai
- Chissà quante banconote ti sei persa
- Ne ho persi tanti soldi, lo sai come li
perdo? Metto i soldi in tasca, quando tiro
fuori il telefono si tirano fuori i soldi e... - Ciao
- E' questo il motivo per cui li perdi, sai
chi li ha trovati tutti? Lui. Io non ho mai
trovato niente e sono una di quelle
persone che se trova il portafogli, a me
è capitato, lo restituisce con
assolutamente tutti i soldi dentro - Io l'ho
aperto, c'era del verde quindi... - Ma era della marijuana?
Però ho preso solo la carta d'identità, lo so andata a di
Mi ha ringraziato in tutte le lingue del mondo - Che carina
- Ah nel senso hai restituito i soldi ma non la carta di identità (Enrico)
- Quella mi serve di più - Lei è una ladra di identità
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, nonostante la mia vita sia un
apostrofo rosa tra le parole mai e una
gioia, sono riuscita ad avere un colpo di
fortuna. Il giorno del mio primo esame
all'università ritrovo come assistente
della mia professoressa un mio amico
e la professoressa dice "Interrogala tu" . 30 e lode - Che c**o! - Ma questa è fantascienza! In realtà non è troppo
fantascienza nella nostra famiglia, non possiamo dire chi non possiamo dire cosa però...
- Gabriele Scilla (Enrico) - Gabriele Scilla
c'ha un bucio di c**o che la metà basta - Ma
non è derivante dal giorno del
compleanno però? Chiaramente no
- Io per esempio porto la mia esperienza
Hai presente gli esami universitari quando
c'è sempre l'assistente, il più... - Si
stronzo - Il più stronzo che c'era
tra i tre, io pescavo sempre quello, come
il drago ad Harry Potter: lo Spinato - Ciao Gu ciao
ospite e ciao Enrico, volevo dirti che ti
seguo da quando avevo tipo 14 anni, no e ora
non ne ho 15, ne ho ben 26. Niente avevo
tipo 13/12 anni, una cosa genere, a quei tempi
ero un po' bullizzato a scuola. Niente un
ragazzo, un bel bullo mi stava spintonando, se non fosse che in quel momento un
piccione stava giusto calandomi in testa.
Questo mi spintona, prende il mio
posto e gli va a finire la cacata in testa. Dopo quel momento
sono andato in chiesa e ho ringraziato Dio perché ho
capito che esiste - Vedi che spesso gli
uccelli sono un pochino la risposta e il
rimedio alla sofferenza e questa qui
secondo me è una grande allegoria di
tutto questo - A me hanno fatto nuova
almeno due volte, cioè nel senso in romano vuol dire
che...m'hanno cacato in testa
Metà sui capelli e metà addosso ma io dovevo vedere  da lì a breve un
ragazzino, sai quando sei piccola, ho pianto
troppo
- E cosa hai fatto alla fine? - Niente che ho
fatto, c'era una fontanella e mi sono
lavata i capelli però il ragazzino l'ho
visto lo stesso con metà testa
bagnata e metà asciutta - Noo - Però c'avevo paura, mi sentivo a disagio perché
secondo me puzzavo di roba di volatile.
Non è andata bene - Ma perché tu sei
sempre stata un cuoricino tenero - Si ecco infatti perché poi la sfiga mi perseguita
- Oh ti adoreranno le persone ne sono
sicuro - Sicuro - Stacco commenti di odio
Chi è questa? Non la vogliamo più vedere! - Sfigata! (Enrico) - Vatti a far cagare in testa dai piccioni
- La mia botta di c**o più grande è sicuramente stata quando sono riuscito a vincere con un solo uccello
l'ultimo livello di Angry Birds
Altre botte di culo nella mia vita non ne ho mai avute e quindi diciamo che è un po' na vita de m***a...un bacio
- Simpatico lui - Ti ringraziamo per questo grande insegnamento, nostro
messia. Qual è stata la tua botta di c**o
più grande? Riesce a ricordarti diciamo
nel grigio di questo passato un
momento in cui tu hai detto "La vita
forse vale la pena viverla" - Si ce l'ho ce l'ho! E sono stata contentissima. Allora
avevo finito la dieta, la prima cosa che
ho fatto è prendermi una kinder delice
alle macchinette e lì ne sono cadute 2, e le ho mangiate entrambe e li ho detto "Uaaa". Forse ho anche pianto
La mia...essere -  .... - Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, presi
al bar una bustina di patatine, in quel
periodo c'erano le sorpresine di Cars.
Nella collezione c'erano sette
personaggi dei film. Nella stessa bustina
di patatine ho trovato 9 sorprese, tutti
e sette i modelli più due doppioni. Ciao a tutti
Allora io sto immaginando come può accadere questa
cosa, cioè nel senso non è che c'è uno
che a un certo punto si è addormentato sotto
al distributore - Lo so io si è fermato il
nastro mentre l'altro nastro sopra
scorreva e quindi "tum tum tum". Non c'è altra  soluzione
- Tu hai visto un sacco di puntate di How it's  mada vero? Hai presente? - Non sai che cosa sia? - No...Che cos'è?
E' quello che ti fanno vedere come vengono fatte le cose, che ne so tipo questo bicchiere, ti fanno
entrare in fabbrica e ti fanno vedere
tutto quello che succede
- Lo sapevo tipo come è fatto - Eh ok, me l'hai detto in una lingua un po' così
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, è tipo la quarta volta che cerco di fare quest'audio. Sono sempre
stata una persona abbastanza fortunata. Ad
esempio l'anno scorso per puro caso ho
trovato un concorso e consisteva nell'inviare il selfie più brutto che potevi
inviare e il selfie più brutto a livello
nazionale avrebbe vinto il telefono, e io
l'ho vinto. Cioè sono così fortunata o
sono così brutta?...Sono anche un
portafortuna: un giorno per sbaglio ho
stampato troppe fototessere e ho iniziato a
distribuirle ai miei amici ovviamente,
che cosa dovevo farci? E ogni volta che la
distribuivo una ad un mio amico il giorno
dopo mi scriveva che aveva preso un bel
voto a scuola e quindi tutti hanno iniziato a chiedere le mie foto - Medjugorje
- ...E usarle come porta fortuna
Porto fortuna
evidentemente e questa cosa è
carina e sono felice. Ciao - Pensa se stampi la
foto del selfie brutto e la distribuisci
Padre Pio - Mi serve il contatto poi me lo passi? - No non credo sia così fortunata
Ragazza di cui non diremo il nome per motivi di
privacy, contatta Morgana, ti lasciamo qua
sotto il suo link anche per farle gli
auguri di buon compleanno anche se
uscirà in ritardo insomma, ma giusto per
farti vedere che il mondo è un posto
buono, che le persone ti vogliono bene
Mandale una tua foto - Ci sono quelle
persone positive eh
A me è successo solo con un vecchietto
che portava fortuna realmente - Cioè? - Ogni
volta che lo incontravo, era del
quartiere, mi succedeva...non un disastro
avevo una giornata normale...E quindi grazie. Grazie per tutte le giornate
canoniche - Che mi hai regalato
- Beh ovviamente la botta di c**o non è
capitata a me però è capitata a mio fratello,
non si è presentato ad un esame
all'università e ha preso 29 - Non ho capito - Come è possibile?
Quindi c'è qualcuno che non ha preso 29?!
La maggior parte delle botte di c**o
coincidono comunque con un colpo di
sfiga di un'altra persona. C'avete mai
pensato? Cioè se trovi 50 euro per terra qualcuno se li è persi
- Io sono una grandissimissima fan della saga di Zelda de videogiochi. Qualche anno fa vennero in concerto
con l'orchestra sinfonica, fecero una tappa a Milano e una a Roma
Io andai a quella di Milano e poi volevo
tornare a quella di Roma però insomma
non mi sembrava il caso di sprecare
altri soldi. Allora la Nintendo fece un
concorso dove potevi vincere dei
biglietti per il concerto della data di
Roma. Mi arrivò l'email che avevo avuto
due biglietti. Non è finita qui. Alla data
di Milano ero andata con quello che al
tempo era il mio ragazzo. Ovviamente mi
sarebbe piaciuto tornare con lui anche
a quella di Roma
però comunque anche mio fratello e mia
sorella, essendo fan della saga
volevano venire e quindi mi trovavo
nella posizione in cui avevo un
biglietto per me e un biglietto per
un'altra persona che non sapevo proprio a
chi dare. Quando mi sono arrivati i
biglietti anziché arrivarmene una sola
coppia me ne sono arrivate due. Quindi ho vinto quattro biglietti
Il concerto fu bellissimo, l'abbiamo visto tutti e quattro insieme - lo vuoi e ti capita - Da domani vi
farò sapere - Incomincia, prova. Adesso mi capita un
qualcosa di bello - Adesso mi capita
qualcosa... - Credici però! Pensa tipo a una cosa
bella - Pizza...Cosa bella - Pizza? - Ho sempre sognato di incontrare Steven
Tyler degli Aerosmith nella mia vita - E per il tuo compleanno...(Enrico)
- Ti giuro faccio un salto - Ti avevo detto di pensare positivo. Allora se
qualcuno sente questo appello di questa
ragazza, qualcuno ai piani alti, qualcuno
che vuole dare per ricevere dalla vita
perché, sappiatelo sempre, per poter
avere bisogna prima dare. Mettetevi una
mano sul cuore, questa ragazza guardatela
è distrutta, sul viale del tramonto,
una ragazza che non ha più nulla
guardatela. Direste che è il suo
compleanno oggi? Per niente, non c'è niente da ridere
- Se non fosse per il decadimento dei suoi
tessuti no, non lo diremmo
Se siete la fuori e conoscete Steven Tyler avete la possibilità di realizzare
un sogno - Fatemeli tirà su, ve prego! I tessuti...
- Io avevo un sogno, avere un sogno! - Io ho un sogno         - Quale sogno - Avere un sogno!
- Lavoravo in un tabacchino e un signore
venne da me e mi disse "Allora gioca
questi tre numeri". Sbagliai a cliccare i
pulsanti e giocai tre numeri a caso.
Questo cominciò a dire le peggiori
cose contro di me, finchè comincia la
partitella, il famoso 10elotto. Si scopre che
il tizio vince 300 euro con i numeri
casuali che io avevo giocato. Insomma
inutile dire che ha chiesto scusa
tremila volte - Ah dopo - Per tutte le
cattiverie che m'aveva detto. Un bacio ciao                           - Opportunista! Vuoi chiedere scusa? Dimezza
la vittoria - No glie li dai tutti perché in realtà l'ha vinti lei   - Vabbè...
Ciao a tutti, sono andata a fare un'unica traversata ad Amsterdam con il mio ragazzo
Arriviamo e troviamo per terra 60 euro. Ci siamo guardati un po' in giro per vedere se erano di qualcuno
Nessuno reclamava i soldi, ce li siamo fumati tutti - Ma che messaggio
mi dai alla fine di questo video? - Non hai
capito Gu, in romano - Ah se lo sono bruciati. Ah ok
Avevo capito altro per il momento. Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questa puntata
io ringrazio con tutto il cuore morgana per
essere venuta il giorno del suo
compleanno insomma all'interno degli studios de
casa mia. Diciamo che ringrazio per
questo prosecco
Ringrazio voi per averci seguito, fatemi
sapere, fateci sapere qual è stata la
botta di c**o più grande - Si può dire botta di c**o? (Enrico)
- Il colpo di fortuna
più grande che vi sia mai capitato...Culo
non si può dire, è arrivata mia cugina. Fatemi sapere qual è stata la vostra...Ma cosa state... - "Pronto pronto"
- Vabbè ragazzi devo andare. Se non l'avete già fatto iscrivetevi a questo canale
attivate la campanella delle notifiche
per non perdervi nessun video. Noi ci
vediamo la prossima settimana con
un'altra puntata sempre alle 14. Ciao - Ciao